[Musique]
mélanie nous a rejoint au plateau est
aujourd'hui va nous parler d'un
rendez-vous junior pour les gourmands
bonjour mélanie bonjour camille en tout
cas pour les fans de chocolat faut aimer
on sait jamais mais c'est tout
simplement parce que dans un peu plus
d'une semaine ce sera pâques les cloches
mon passé et sonner le lundi 17 avril
elles sont même en avance dans certains
endroits comme à rambouillet alors avec
les vacances les cloches ont déjà caché
des oeufs dans les jardins du château et
pourrait militer leur chocolat il faut
faire preuve de connaissances écouter et
un petit plan et des énigmes
ils partent dans les jardins à la
recherche d'offres en carton à ces
grands qui leur permettent de répondre à
des questions et une fois qu'ils ont
répondu à toutes ses questions ils
reviennent à la boutique du château
et s'ils ont trouvé la bonne réponse on
leur offre un petit sachet de chocolats
alors le plan est disponible à l'entrée
du château l'activité coûte 7 euros 50
et en plus de la chasse les enfants de 3
à 12 ans peuvent faire un atelier manuel
en fonction des âges
alors ils peuvent créer un lapin avec
des bandes de papier qui vont colorer
ont réalisé là aussi un masque de lapin
dans tous les cas des ouvriers ou bien
mais qu'ils y aillent
alors attention ces animations ne sont
pas disponibles les week-ends et toutes
les informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet du château qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
et si les informations sont bonnes mais
l'ani les cloches ne devrait pas tarder
à passer à 50 ans on y mène aussi aux
informations sont bonnes tes risques
c'est un petit lapin qui vous les a
donnés mais elle a peut-être en allant
château j'étais pas loin de la bergerie
nationale donc du coup dans la première
ce sera à l'honneur samedi prochain le
15 avril dans le parc de l'après vandry
il y aura plus de 1400 à retrouver et
parmi ces 1400 eu quatre seront en or et
ça permettra de remporter un oeuf géant
chocolat une autre chasse aux phoques
est mis à voisins le bretonneux cette
fois le lundi 17 avril le rendez vous
est donné au parc de la croix de bois à
partir de 16 heures je pense que là il
ya de quoi satisfaire tous les gourmands
un oui du chocolat partout et sous
toutes ses formes mais à consommer avec
moi
des rations bien sûr merci mélanie entre
que nous avoir parlé de ces rendez vous